on this Monday night grief in the
aftermath of a mass murder at least 18
victims 16 crime scenes in rural Nova
Scotia this is something that we are
dealing with right now that is
heartbreak on top of other heartbreaks
questions about the RCMP s response and
the search for a motive
fighting kovat 19 the military's new
mission inside Quebec care homes and
below zero oil prices plunge to a record
low
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
it is unthinkable a quiet rural corner
of Nova Scotia staggering under the
weight of a despicable crime one of the
worst mass killings in Canadian history
this happened in small towns Porter Peak
Truro Milford an Enfield our places
where people have deep roots places
where people know their neighbors and
look out for one another
now these communities are in mourning
and Canada is in mourning with him - the
grandparent who lost a child the
children who lost a parent - the
neighbor who lost a friend
the RCMP say more than 18 people men and
women are dead plus the gunman it
appears that some of the victims were
known to the suspect and others were
targeted and not known to the suspect 16
crime scenes are being investigated
including five houses burned to the
ground there may be more victims inside
for 12 hours the gunman continued his
rampage able to keep going for so long
because he was disguised driving a mock
RCMP vehicle and wearing a police
uniform among his victims RCMP constable
Heidi Stephenson our hearts are broken
my heart is broken murder on this scale
is hard to comprehend that it happened
in the middle of a pandemic when anxiety
was already high and when people were
told to stay home and sit to save lives
just adds to the agony it was at home
that some of the victims died we have
complete coverage tonight beginning with
Elizabeth McCaffrey on what we're
learning about the victims
she was a gifted violinist and seventeen
year old Emily tuck shared her music as
a way to entertain and encourage those
told to stay at home during kovat 19
Emily's mother Jolene Oliver said to
love poetry and books and father Aaron
tuck remembered as a handy man with a
gift for leather work just one of many
families torn apart the sad part is is
that they're all going together but in a
way because of how close they were I'm
glad that none of them are actually
suffering for each other because it
would just they would never be able to
survive without each other they were
very close at a time when we are
praising nurses as heroes too are being
honored Heather O'Brien and Kristen
Beaton both worked for the Victorian
order of nurses which today described
O'Brien as a wife mother and grandmother
who shared her deep caring of others as
a vo and nurse for nearly 17 years and
beaten a continuing care worker as a
caring and compassionate member of the
Victorian order of nurses team Lisa
McCauley taught grade 3 & 4 on Twitter
her regional center for education says
she was beloved by both her students and
colleagues a couple both of whom were
correctional officers are among those
killed Sean McLeod worked at the
Springhill institution for more than 20
years and Alanna Jenkins at the Nova
institution for women in Truro another
couple Greg and Jamie Blair ran a
natural gas and propane business near
the area where the massacre took place
54 year old Gina Goulet was a two-time
cancer survivor from Shabana khadi and
an avid recreational Fisher and the
Regional Municipality of Durham says Don
and Frank Madsen were longtime residents
of their community Don was a former
long-term care worker constable Heidi
Stevenson was the first casualty to be
named in the tragedy the 23 year member
of the force was killed while responding
to the chaos this weekend she leaves
behind her husband and two children more
victims will be named in the days to
come
but RCMP constable Chad Morrison will
not be one of them the 11-year veteran
made it home from the hospital on Monday
and was greeted warmly by his community
in Enfield he's healing from gunshot
wounds in what is perhaps the one bit of
good news to emerge from this tragedy
Elizabeth McCaffrey Global News Halifax
the investigation is still in the early
stages here's what we know of the
timeline at 11:30 on Saturday night RCMP
respond to a firearms complaint in the
town of Porter pick the public advised
to stay inside and lock their doors when
police arrived they find multiple
casualties nearly nine hours later the
RCMP tweet that officers remain on scene
calling it an active shooter situation
they identify the gunman as 51 year old
Gabriel Wortman considered armed and
dangerous
the suspect is then seen again 30
kilometers east of Porter pick around
Truro driving a car that appears to be
an RCMP cruiser and wearing what appears
to be a police uniform
he was then seen heading from Brookfield
towards Halifax along the trans-canada
highway and after an encounter with
police on highway 2 drives off in a
small SUV the rampage ends in a standoff
at this gas station in Enfield near the
trans-canada that's where the gunman
died there is no known motive at this
point police say no note from the gunman
has been found
Ross Lord on what we do know about the
investigation in the community where the
killing spree started it's going to take
a long time for the world to make sense
again and still I believe shocked and
you know befuddled don't really
understand what's going on devastated by
what happened and afraid the news could
become even worse we haven't heard from
our friends and we hope they're okay the
son has been trying to get a hold of
them with no and still hasn't had any
word investigators say there are 16
crime scenes including five houses burnt
to the ground
we believe there may be victims still
within the
remains of those homes they still don't
know gabriel Wortman motive why he went
from a professional denturist to
perpetrator of one of the biggest murder
sprees in canadian history his high
school yearbook caption suggests his
future may include being an RCMP officer
no one expected him to disguise himself
as a Mountie so he could kill
unsuspecting victims not million years
not in a million years like I said he
was just and it's cliche right I mean
you see this all the time when there's a
murderer you know the neighbors say how
quiet and friendly he was he was he
worked primarily at this denture clinic
in Dartmouth Nova Scotia the owner of
this strip mall says Wortman rented a
second clinic here in Halifax for more
than 20 years paying his rent on time
and recently driving what looked like an
old police car with the decals removed
but reflective tape still visible a
picture released at the height of the
rampage suggests the car had been
dressed up to be an almost perfect
replica his ability to move around the
province undetected was surely greatly
benefited by the fact that he had a
police or a vehicle that looked
identical and in every way to a marked
police car Wortman was also wearing a
partial or full RCMP uniform after the
first 9-1-1 calls Nova Scotia RCMP
limited communication to its Twitter
page there was a gap of eight hours
overnight between tweets and unlike the
Cova 19 message released over the Easter
weekend there was no emergency alert
leading to some pointed questions about
whether the public was sufficiently
warned there are several investigations
underway into the chaotic effort to stop
the gunman the arms-length serious
incident response team will investigate
the final take down and another incident
involving RCMP members discharging
firearms the Mounties themselves will
review a third incident also surrounding
the use of force just the start of what
is sure to be an unprecedented review of
how this happened and how authorities
responded Donna Ross lured in Halifax
thinks because this happened in
midst of a pandemic there can be no
coming together at funerals we'll have
more on plans for mourning a little
later
right now large gatherings are still
banned of course because of the risk of
spreading the corona virus here's a look
at the numbers in Canada right now there
are over 36,000 confirmed cases of kovat
19 in Canada that only reflects those
people who have been tested more than
1,600 people are known to have died from
it
more than 900 of those people are in
Quebec the hardest-hit province 62 more
deaths were reported there today some
staff in hospitals in Quebec including
nurses and orderlies are now being
redeployed to long term care homes
that's where the outbreaks are worst and
where help is needed the most
as Mike Armstrong reports even the
military is doing what it can this is
one of five teams of Canadian Armed
Forces soldiers deployed Monday to
Quebec seniors residences it's likely
not a task any of them predicted when
they joined the military but that
doesn't seem to be a problem it is most
certainly unusual but we are ready to
adapt and overcome any challenge in our
way and we're mostly proud to be here
now Quebec seniors residences have been
hit hard by kovat 19 they have about
4,000 cases in about a hundred and 50
facilities they're also short about
2,000 full-time workers at this
residence one ward over the weekend was
staffed by just two Auxiliary nurses for
40 people they were overwhelmed to fill
the gap the military team of 14 nurses
medical technicians and medical
assistants hit the ground running
activities of daily living we call it so
I Tyla ting feeding grooming walking
assistance all we barely got in and we
were already working knees deep in it we
were we were put to work as fast as they
could now urgent help was needed in Nova
Scotia as well this seniors facility
went from 50 kovat 19 cases friday to a
hundred and 50 now they also have 40
staff off work and had to call in help
from the provincial health authority
we've had to reach out we
not able to manage this on our own we
were doing very very well
up until the last couple of days we're
still in the middle of a battle in
Ontario the government says it's numbers
overall have likely peaked but that the
situation in seniors residences
continues to be a major concern
Mike Arms from Global News Laval Quebec
public health officials in Ontario say
the restrictions on people's movements
have slowed the spread and though there
were more than 600 new cases confirmed
today that's the biggest single-day
increase so far the pandemic as Mike
mentioned appears to have peaked several
weeks ahead of what was forecast
Jeff's simple explains what that means
this family-run Toronto clothing store
is hanging by a thread surviving this is
gonna be very difficult clothes now for
six weeks it's owner expects the
business won't survive another month
under lockdown I got to open this
business back up I've got inventory to
sell and I've got rent to pay and I've
got kids to feed but he and his fellow
Ontarians just received some much-needed
good news today we saw new modeling that
shows there's some light at the end of
the tunnel the Ontario government says
the provinces covet 19 outbreak appears
to have peaked a month earlier than
expected we still have far to go but
thanks to our collective efforts we're
in a better position today Ontario is
now expecting this outbreak will see
20,000 cases of Kovan 19 that's a
quarter of what the province had
predicted just a couple of weeks ago and
is even better than their best case
scenario which is obviously encouraging
the cases are not going to skyrocket
this infectious disease doctor helped to
produce the latest models and says one
area where they underestimated the
outbreak was in long-term care homes
sadly we just didn't acknowledge how
vulnerable our vulnerable populations
truly were but in the wider population
many are now wondering how much longer
this lockdown will last I've been
waiting for hip replacement surgery for
almost 50
I'm wondering when you will be able to
start the surgeries again
Ontario's hospitals cancelled
non-emergency surgeries to make room for
kovat 19 patients and now find
themselves with a surplus of intensive
care beds the challenge how to expand
service while also bracing for a second
wave of cases it was very relatively
simple to stop the system it's actually
much more complex to actually turn it
back on again experts expect a slow
easing of restrictions to begin in a
matter of weeks and small businesses
could be among the first in line Jeff
sample Global News Toronto a crude
awakening coming up oil prices sink into
uncharted territory
the price of oil has dropped into
negative territory for the first time in
history there's too much being produced
and not enough demand and the impact on
Canada is huge David akin has been
watching this slide and David this
collapse is putting even more pressure
on Ottawa to offer a lifeline oh
absolutely consider this Donna on Friday
you would have paid about $18.00 for a
barrel of the benchmark West Texas
Intermediate you would have paid 18
bucks today the producers will pay you
37 dollars to take that barrel off their
hands they simply don't have any room to
store it last week the OPEC plus nations
agreed to cut global production by 10
million barrels a day but demand has
dropped 30 million barrels a day that
means 20 million barrels a day are being
produced that no one can use here in
Canada one major producer Huskie said
today it would cut production by 80,000
barrels a day Huskie and some other
producers also announced more cuts to
their capital plans more salary
reductions more job cuts the federal
government did announce some help for
the sector Friday but conservatives say
the help was too little too late it is
woefully inadequate for an energy sector
and economy already decimated by this
Liberal government what will the Prime
Minister's plan be when 7 percent of our
GDP hundreds of thousands of jobs and
hundreds of billions of dollars in
federal and provincial tax revenues are
permanently lost meanwhile the Canadian
Association of Petroleum producers told
the government before this dramatic
decline in price that the industry would
need between 27 and 30 billion dollars
in assistance in order to survive Donna
all right David akin in Ottawa thank you
a meatpacking plant in southern Alberta
is temporarily shutting down because of
an outbreak of Coe bid 19 the Cargill
meatpacking plant employs more than
2,000 people there have been more than
350 cases of kovin 19 linked to it a
company spokesperson is encouraging all
employees to get tested production will
stop once the meat already in the plant
is processed ahead why some Sydney
beaches are reopening
people return to some of Sydney
Australia's most popular beaches today
more than three weeks after they were
shut down only exercise is allowed at
the three city beaches strict physical
distancing measures remain in place
sunbathing and gatherings are still
prohibited other famous beaches in
Australia remain shut down India is also
starting to ease restrictions with some
farmers and manufacturers back at work
the country though recorded its biggest
daily spike in cases today more than
1,500 new infections Singapore also
recorded its biggest single-day spike
many of those infected there are foreign
workers who typically are low paid and
live in crowded housing three cruise
ships that have been sailing ever since
this pandemic began are due to dock
today 18 Canadians and seven Canadian
crew members were on the three ships
passengers would normally leave that
ship every few days but haven't been
able to for six weeks after the captain
decided to make the long journey home
next how do we grieve in these uncertain
times
there are families across this country
mourning those who have died of kovat 19
and in those small Nova Scotian
communities where so many people were
murdered it is natural of course a
normal to come together to mourn but
kovat 19 is robbing us of our rituals
and there will be no big memorials no
traditional funerals with me as Pastor
Steven Adams he's from Faith Baptist
Church in great village Nova Scotia
that's just down the road from porta
pick pastor Adams first our condolences
to everyone in the communities there the
grief must be so acute and this is small
town Nova Scotia everyone is closely
connected how are people coping people I
think are still in shock and which I
think most people who have gone through
any kind of trauma or observed people
going through trauma would appreciate
the reality of that it's it is to use
the word like overwhelming would be a
gross understatement the premier says
there can be no mass gatherings to
grieve that Kovach 19 will not pause
because of the pain that must add
heartbreak to the heartbreak I don't
know if it adds to the heartbreak but
it's sure it sure makes it more
difficult to be you know there for other
people and have other people provide you
know comfort there are plans for a
virtual vigil on Friday I know that is
still in the works but do you know what
it might look like I'm not part of the
planning committee for that I have been
asked if I would participate and I said
that I would I know that a number of
people have been asked to participate
community people and and and people you
know across the country and the people
here that are impacted so closely you
know who've lost family members there
they're in shock and grief and and so
we're grieving along with them and to
try to just try to wrap our minds around
that is
that's difficult these are these are
very difficult days we're going through
tremendous times of loss and grief but
this situation is compounded not not
just by the fact that it's so immense
and involves so many people and some
people and so many families but also
because it's it's become a global
grieving I don't want for us to lose in
all of us the people whose lives have
been torn apart and whose hearts have
been shattered by this we're talking
children without parents we're talking
about teachers and health care workers
family members right so I just don't
want those people and their and their
pain and to be to be somehow lost in all
of the the outpouring none of us do
Pastor Steven Adams and Nova Scotia
things that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna freezin we leave you
tonight with some consoling words from
Nova Scotia's premier he says the best
way to honor the dead is to protect the
living and not risk spreading covin 19
by gathering has also asked people to
tie the Nova Scotia tartan to a tree or
put it in the window it may not seem
like enough but for now it's a way for
all of us to come together without
coming together and james dyson shared
this tribute to the group the ultimate
online Nova Scotia kitchen party
[Music]
his rendition of Amazing Grace dedicated
to those who died in this tragedy thanks
for watching take care of yourselves
[Music]